[Musique]
consommer de la com' 26 vous allez en
entendre beaucoup parler ces prochains
jours car l'enjeu est évidemment
colossal face à l'accélération du
réchauffement climatique c'est cette
incapacité collective qui va entre
copains qui fait qu'on a un cirque et
que derrière plus personne n'y croit ça
et donc là on peut penser même
aujourd'hui à rares tout début de la
coop 26 ski ça débouchera sur rien du
tout la faune qui qui naviguent autour
des coques 26 c ce sont des gros cabinet
d'avocats des groupes des grosses ong
des organisations supranationales comme
l'union européenne qui sont en fait des
machines à faire du cash car cette coque
26 apparaît de plus en plus comme la
conférence de la dernière chance pour la
planète selon l'organisation
météorologique mondiale
la période 2015-2020 t1 sera
probablement la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée
si glasgow échoue c'est tout qui aura
échoué
la corde paris se sera effondré au
premier bilan ça ne sert strictement à
rien si ce n'est à nourrir certains de
ses gros acteurs des cabinets d'avocats
des
décors des campagnes de communication
etc et à côté ça les vrais enjeux ils ne
sont surtout pas aborder c'est ça que je
reproche mois aux écolos c'est cette
hypocrisie la mauvaise nouvelle est que
nous avons déjà atteint une
concentration de dioxyde de carbone si
élevé que la fonte des glaciers la
hausse du niveau de la mer se
poursuivront dans tous les cas pour les
centaines d'années à venir
1,5 degré c'est l'augmentation des
températures prévue par la majorité des
scientifiques
d'ici 2040 notre objectif c'est le 1,5
degré pour la fin du siècle la clé de
notre action collective et que dans les
jours qui viennent avant la clôture de
cette coop et puisse y avoir
suffisamment d'engagement pour revenir
des stratégies nationales qui
crédibilise cet objectif à glasgow deux
grands absents la russie et la chine
deux des plus gros pollueurs de la
planète
visiblement emmanuel macron n'a toujours
pas digéré la perte du contrat du siècle
avec l'australie
in fine à nos
hayden cinq anneaux online
c'est
pourquoi je suis mis du travail à
[Musique]
hop vous faites tapoter la main et vous
avez l'air d'un gamin à l'image
maquereau a su répondre aux gestes en
reprenant la main de maître une petite
image qui a gagné le concours lépine
cette année le concours des inventions
et bien c'est un informaticien de 37 ans
qui s'appelle omar seck il est
l'inventeur de cette table basse qui
peut se transformer en poste de
télétravail tiens c'est dans l'air du
temps il est 18h30 hier lorsqu'un
individu encagoulé temps d'incendier un
bus à vaulx en velin près de lyon
l'homme lance des objets enflammés à
l'intérieur du véhicule stationné
alors que des passagers sont à
l'intérieur
je rappelle que nous sommes dans une
ambassade française je répète française
et qui fait la loi après plusieurs
tentatives vaines l'homme n'a pas le
temps de s'échapper il est rattrapé par
un témoin et violemment frappé au sol au
milieu des déchets encore en flammes
en france on est toujours sans nouvelles
de trois jeunes alpinistes français
trois hommes tous âgés d'une vingtaine
d'années s'était lancé dans une
expédition de haut niveau au népal la
fédération française des clubs alpins et
de montagne dit avoir retrouvé trois
sacs ainsi que du matériel de bivouac
selon elle l'espoir de retrouver des
survivants est à présent quasi nul